[Applause]
foreign
keep your head down
there you go today we're teaming up with
the amazing juggler Josh Porter our plan
is to create as many tricks as possible
in only five hours oh my God the clock
starts now first trick show of the day
first try yeah first try all right
incoming all right
I actually think let's move the table
against the black person now the setup
is perfect so now it'll be first try
here we go incoming ready
foreign
nice it's like we've been doing it for
years yeah now let's try and keep it
going like a continuous cycle oh yeah
that's easy okay
[Music]
yeah we can go in Forever nice sweet
okay so already two in the bag all right
playing while juggling okay I'm gonna
beat you okay
[Music]
maybe not
Josh I was getting mad when I can't do
stuff I've never done before
[Music]
oh my God so impressive what that was
good that was so sick I really didn't
expect that to be possible this is what
I'm currently able to do and also switch
like this it's not bad right left right
left so let's go for four catches
[Music]
I need one more hand to do this now stop
I I was gonna stop
there should be a big old Gap right here
yeah but you're getting that Gap all
cluttered up
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
come on come on
easier the green could come all the way
here and then back
I know this somehow looks so satisfying
and the sound is so nice on the table
oh my God
[Music]
I cannot believe we got that that was so
good
[Music]
they were like this would be easy I'm
like no there's no way I actually didn't
feel in the beginning of it it's
possible at all but that's how you do it
in the lens I actually like to pause
them quite quickly after each other more
likely to fall over like that yeah
that's probably true yeah one
two
oh sorry sorry
absolutely brand new Sensei rocket just
look at the surface
one two
three
let's go nice well done
time for some spooning yes this is one
of my favorite favorite tricks
spoons into cups so you focus on that
spoon and that cup and that's it first
try I'm gonna say like 26 26 nine tries
really close definitely higher than what
you just did
[Music]
four out of five this is the one
okay let's go it's a very satisfying
trick thanks hold on hold on
ready yep
oh that's actually very hard to do it's
my turn yeah
[Music]
no
there is oh yes my neck hurts I need a
massage
[Music]
Ready set go
you missed my own ball
[Music]
[Applause]
s
all right we ready let's go yeah that
Tempo will be good if we can get it
that's pretty tough motor ball yeah
[Music]
yeah that was nice
I'm gonna teach you how to do a 360. I
mean three up looks like that
but we're just gonna work on a one up
360. yeah so one up turn around and
continue juggling it'll be best if you
throw your high throw with your left
hand and then you catch it in your right
hand
that wasn't bad not bad not bad you were
still kind of doing a little bit of this
which is will make you really dizzy
no there you go that's nice
no oh geez
why are you squatting
watch out
there you go that was nice that was nice
yeah that was it and now you gotta do
all three up and then two spins
okay yeah I've got it one two three
almost maybe just try to go like uh so
that it's above your head
yeah it'll be this high and then you can
watch directly to the camera and then
I'll go like
okay like that
[Music]
jeez
yeah
okay it's close
okay all right
[Music]
there we got it whoa that was the orange
one that was it
all right we got it clean we throw you
one and then you just knock it in does
that water in it it's still alive
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
my God
oh look at that
one two three
yes that's really good and then you'll
do one slow lob going through the past
couple of times
not the easiest one this one either
let's just go once through the hoops and
then we play like the point to the end
three two one
all right now it's time three
two one
[Music]
hundred percent that was it I actually
stopped playing
I feel like all the times you guys said
one I was like I don't know I have no
idea that one I know it was full make
sure to subscribe to both channels and
let us know who should be our next
Challenger until next time